- On this episode,
Charlamagne Tha God comes by
and talks Black Privilege.
- Opportunity Comes
to Those Who Create It.
In bookstores now.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them
This is
The #AskGaryVee Show
- Hey everybody, this
is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this episode 248
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
We flip the script.
(Cha laughs)
Usually I'm in your world.
- Yep.
- I'm excited about this.
- Yeah man.
- For the three
people that don't know
who you are, let them know.
- Charlamagne Tha God,
the prime minister of pissing
people off, the ruler of
rubbin' you the wrong way,
the architect of aggravation,
that's me.
Now author of Black Privilege:
Opportunity Comes
to Those Who Create It,
radio personality,
TV personality,
professional slang-spitter,
heavy-hitter, shit-talker.
- Wow.
- My man,GaryVee.
- You know, you really
got your thing down.
That was really strong.
(Cha laughs)
So listen, one
that that excites me is,
you're interesting to me.
You're interesting to
me because I think you
really, really, really get it.
- Mhmmm.
- The reason I've really
enjoyed gettin' to know you
and your crew is like
I just think you get it.
And what I mean
by getting it, is
I think you're intent is good.
I love that.
- Everything is about intent.
- And then I think you
understand where attention is.
And I like the way that
you put yourself in positions
to be heard, to hack culture.
- Mhmmm.
- I just think it's smart.
And I think you're a nice guy.
- Yeah, thank you.
I appreciate that.
My grandmother would
always told me manners
will take you where money won't.
So, I mean, I don't
have like a formal education.
I didn't go to
college or anything like that.
So all I have is like--
- [Gary] What you got.
- That's what I got.
When I walk in a room,
I just try to, you know,
show love to everybody,
treat everybody the way
I would want to be treated.
Treat 'em with respect.
And you know, it seems
good things come from it.
- Now you're
promoting this book,
this is coming out
now or shortly when?
- April 18th.
I don't know when this
podcast is gonna air, but--
- Now.
- Now, okay.
- Live, questions get
ready, Facebook get ready.
We're about to do some calls.
- Oh, we live.
- Oh, we're Facebook live--
- Oooh!
- Oh, what, that
wakes you up a little more?
Okay, good.
- The book is out April 18th.
Okay?
You can pre-order now at Amazon,
Barnes and Nobles,
Cedar-books.com.
- How'd you get
all these fancy people
to give you quotes?
- That's just years and
years of networking, man.
I mean, I got
Lena Dunham on the back.
Lena Dunham is
somebody I met maybe
like a couple years ago.
I call her my
problematic princess.
You know, cause I've
always been a fan of "Girls".
And she started responding
to me on social media.
You know, social media
connects the world.
If it was six
degrees of separation before,
now it's like one or two.
- [Gary] It's true.
- Issa Rae, you know,
somebody who I--
- A lot goes down on DM.
- Yeah, yeah.
Issa Rae, I don't
know if you know Issa Rae.
Issa Rae has a show
on HBO called "Insecure".
And she's one of those
people that had just utilized
the digital
world to her advantage,
'cause she started off
with a web show called
"Awkward Black Girl".
Turned into a book,
now it's a hit
television show
called "Insecure".
Stephen Colbert,
South Carolina legend.
I've done the Colbert show.
- How'd you feel about South
Carolina losin' final four?
Were you sad?
- It hurt, I went
to the game though.
- [Gary] You were
really into it, right?
- Yeah, my wife went to the
University of South Carolina.
I had a lot of
sex in the quad house.
You know, a lot of
unprotected sex back in the day
on the University of
South Carolina campus.
- Don't promote,
you're gonna get in trouble.
Don't promote unprotected sex.
- Oh, I'm married now.
- No, Trojan the
brand could be watching.
I'm not talking
about people, brands.
- I did used to wear
magnums when I was,
you know, having
sex with other women.
- I see this book everywhere,
like you're really doing it.
- I'm tryin', man, I'm tryin'
to follow your lead.
- Well you did, you
followed that little
hack direct to Amazon.
- Absolutely.
- So, what is
exciting you right now?
You've obviously got this.
What is the
premise of Black Privilege?
- The premise of Black
Privilege: Opportunity Comes
to Those Who
Create It, it's this
whole concept in
America of white privilege,
which is a very real concept,
you know, but I feel like--
- Wealth privilege.
- No matter what
you look like. That's real.
- Wealth privilege is
real, celebrity privilege is.
There's all type of
different privileges.
- Celebrity privilege may
be the realest of them all.
- It might be
realest of them all.
- That's why
Donald Trump is president.
- It might be the
realest of them all, right?
- I absolutely agree with that.
So I just feel like you have
to embrace what you have.
Like, I was created a black man.
Like how you always talk
about when a person had sex.
One sperm cell out of millions.
- It's just crazy.
- One sperm cell--
- You got lucky.
- Out of millions
created us, so it's a privilege
just to be alive
and be breathin'.
So for me, I am what I am.
I'm a black man in
America, so I have to
find privilege within that.
Like I can't
look at a white person
and be like, he's got
more privilege than me
because of the color
of his skin even though
that may be true.
I still gotta live.
- It's a mindset.
- Like it's like sports, right?
Like, okay, he's
faster so, you know,
drill into him
cause he's not as strong.
Do something.
- So I shouldn't run?
I shouldn't even compete,
just 'cause he's faster than me?
- Or I actually, genuinely
think like, look he's faster.
So like, I'm stronger.
I'm gonna bash him
down for three quarters
and by the end, I'll win.
- Absolutely.
- Like, and by the
way, to black privilege,
which I genuinely believe that
in a world that we live in,
and by the way, I believe
in all those privileges,
wealth, white, celebrity.
It's a better time to be
black than it was 30, 40,
50, 60, 70, 80 years ago.
Especially,
when hip hop culture,
there's not a white kid that
works that works VaynerMedia
that's isn't
affected by hip hop culture.
- Oh yeah, I mean black
people have changed the world.
It's so funny,
they talk about people
co-opting our
culture, but you look
at a movie like "Get Out".
They want to co-opt
our consciousness, period.
They want to co-opt our spirit.
And I just feel
like it's a spirit
that is permeating
the whole planet.
Like everything starts and end,
to me, with hip hop culture.
Like they still like to
use the term pop culture,
but pop culture
just means popular.
What's the most
popular culture out right now?
Hip hop.
- Let's go to the phones, Andy.
And so, let's talk about hip hop
while Andy gets the first call.
Who's exciting you right now?
- Right now
I still love Big Sean.
I think Big Sean is the
best rapper out right now.
Kendrick--
- Why do you think
he's the best rapper?
- 'Cause I'm just
simple with it.
Lyrics, delivery, bars,
you know, different flows.
I think Big Sean got that.
For whatever reason, people
don't take him serious enough.
- Why?
- I don't know.
It's interesting with him,
like somebody like Kendrick
can say something and everybody
holds on to his every word.
- 'Cause Kendrick plays
that role where he's like,
he positioned himself
like thoughtful like that.
- [Hashim] Hello?
- True.
- Hello, what's your name?
- [Hashim] Hashim.
Hashim Lafond.
- My man, you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show with Cha.
- [Hashim] Yes!
(group laughter)
- What's up, my guy?
- [Hashim] C Tha God, what's up?
- What's up, brother?
How are you?
- [Hashim] I'm good, man.
I watch
The Breakfast Club all the time.
I watch GaryVee all the time.
- You sound like
a very smart man.
(laughter)
- You've got good taste.
- [Hashim] I'm trying
to get my life in order.
- So what's
you're question, my man?
- [Hashim] Alright,
so my name is Hashim.
I have my wife, Bennetta.
We've been together,
we're high school sweethearts.
I have two baby girls right now.
Two-year-old and one-year-old.
Another one, born on the way.
And we've been
documenting our life of Facebook
so far for a while now.
- What's a while?
- Since it first came out.
- Okay.
- So you mean you've been--
- [Hashim] Like
there's pictures of us.
- Yeah you've been
putting up pictures.
Okay.
So you mean like
every other person on Earth?
- [Hashim] Yes, yes.
- Okay, I just
wanted to establish that.
- Yeah, my two-year-old daughter
had a video that
had 8,000,000 views
of just her
saying goo goo gah gah.
- Oh God, now you
think she's gonna be famous.
- Well, she is famous.
- [Hashim] Oh it's a definite.
I'm an artist, but...
I'm an artist, I'm a filmmaker.
I do as much as I can
to provide for my family.
- So do your thing.
- [Hashim] I do things
that actually get me famous
but my kids are naturals.
They became models
and stuff like that.
- I love it.
- [Hashim] Now my
question is, how do I monetize
something like this?
We have a huge following
and I wanna figure out
how do you monetize that.
- Have you had
brand's reach out to you?
- [Hashim] We've
reached out to brands.
My wife does that.
She's reached out to
different baby products
and stuff like that
and they've been
giving us free things
to take pictures of
us and stuff like that
but--
- How many followers
do you have on Instagram
and how many
followers do you have
on your Facebook fan page?
- [Hashim] On Facebook,
I have 16,000
and on Instagram I have 1,300.
- You're not big enough.
- I'm verified on Facebook,
but--
- Yeah, I mean I'm
not even gonna lie.
That's always a
difficult question for me
'cause I don't think you
should try to monetize fame.
There's nothing attached to it.
Like, what are you famous for?
Like, if she
had an actual skill,
or a talent or something--
- [Gary] Well, she does.
I think this is
actually an interesting debate,
because I would say escapism
is the fame. Right?
So when people say
what is she famous for?
Is watching men run
around and throw a ball
into a basket or throw it
around and run over each other,
when was that considered a
huge skill and when wasn't it?
You see where I'm going?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's a really
interesting time, right?
Like, what becomes...
It's amazing to
watch America, this market,
make certain things skills.
Kids did not get paid to be
good at skateboarding in 1960.
They do now because
people will watch it.
So famous for the sake of famous
has been around forever.
An icon named Zsa Zsa Gabor--
- Nah, but they're not though.
- But they are. Zsa Zsa Gabor
wasn't known for anything.
She tried to act.
Everybody can try to act.
I think it just
comes down to attention.
- So Zsa Zsa Gabor was
the original Kim Kardashian
is what you're saying?
- One hundred percent.
- Okay, got you.
- It's true.
- I just feel like
you still have
to have something
attached to it.
- Listen, the
attach is escapism.
I think if you're pretty,
that's escapism.
Eyes are on you.
It's called modeling.
- Pretty girl privilege.
- That's real.
(Cha laughs)
That might be actually,
let's take the fame one out.
That might really be the one.
- That might be the one.
- My man, listen.
Here's the punchline.
I think you might
be slightly delusional
in a very sweet way.
I can already tell you're
a good guy. You're just...
The numbers,
and I haven't even looked at
the engagement rates
against that top line
following account.
But, everybody's
got 2,000 followers.
Everybody's got
16,000 followers.
You can't monetize
because brands don't think
it's special enough,
because you don't
have enough of attention.
You're a TV show, bro.
You're a TV show.
You just don't
have enough viewers.
- [Hashim] Okay.
- Right? So I think,
of course, you think
your kids are the most talented.
I literally think
my two are as well.
It's just what we do. Right?
- Yeah.
- You've gotta
let the math speak.
It's great that
you're getting free stuff
with those numbers.
That means your wife's a
hustler and a salesperson
and she's doing her thing.
Getting free
stuff at those numbers
is already an accomplishment.
I kinda wanna hire her.
Send her my way,
because that's a good job
for that small of a base.
To start getting paid
five, 10, $15,000 by a brand,
you've gotta get those
numbers and engagement up.
Period.
- [Hashim] Alright.
- Alright. Good luck.
- What you said is interesting
too, about escapism though,
'cause I think sometimes
you can have those numbers
just because people are bored.
I don't know if I want people
just to be tuning into me
just because they're bored.
- But they're tuning
into everything because
bored is the slang term for
I'm not doing
something right now
and I want to do something else.
You know what's
really interesting?
I'm also fascinated by
when the political climate
is rough, like it is now,
like you know,
when people are scared,
during times of war...
So during World War II,
one of the things that grew
was the circus.
People didn't have
money for porridge.
And they were
going to see the circus,
because when life's hard,
you need to just do
shit that doesn't matter.
Like the Jets.
The Jets means so much
more to me than people realize
because it's the one
place that I really care
about something that
really doesn't matter.
- It does, though.
It's a different
level of excitement.
You get dressed.
- Some people feel
that way about runway shows.
Some people feel that way
about a new album dropping.
Some people feel that
about kids playing hacky sack.
Everybody's got
their different interests.
Rap wasn't music, remember?
Until it was.
- Yeah
- Like everybody
tried to dis the new thing.
E-Sports, right,
Instagram models.
- [Jonathan] Hello?
- Hello, my man
this is GaryVee and
you're on The #AskGaryVee Show.
- He said
Instagram models. (laughs)
- [Jonathan] Holy Christ, okay.
- What's your name, man?
- [Jonathan] I'm Jonathan.
- All right, Jonathan.
- [Jonathan] Leclair
from Richland, Washington.
- I love it, man,
what's your question?
- [Jonathan] Okay, so,
when you started
the 2017 Flip Challenge,
I decided to try
doing that selling books.
- Let me just say one thing.
Let me say one thing,
Jonathan, I apologize.
'Cause it just
has to be mentioned
for everybody who
might not know this.
The reason the 2017
Flip Challenge happened
was because I was
on The Breakfast Club,
we were doing our thing,
Envy said, "Okay, give a
practical piece of advice,"
because I'm good,
I didn't fold and feel sad,
I came up with one on the spot,
which was go buy stuff
at the dollar
store and thrift stores,
sell stuff in your house,
and now there
are tens of thousands
of people selling stuff.
I'm getting
crazy emails of like,
"I had no money, now
I have $4,000,
"'cause I sold all my
clothes that I don't wear."
So it's been huge,
I'm glad you jumped on it,
and thank you, Charlamagne,
or having me on the show
to create that
little micro movement.
Go ahead, Jonathan.
- [Jonathan] Yeah, okay, so
I've made progress on that,
but it's going
slower than I'd like.
I've only made a
couple thousand dollars.
- Only made a couple thousand.
- I wanna punch him in the face.
- Oh my God.
- Punch him.
- Only made a couple thousand?
Come on, bro,
how much did you have before?
- Zero!
- [Jonathan] Well, we
put in like 2,000, so.
- Okay, and so, good.
And so, what's, how
much are you working?
Like how much
are you spending time
going to thrift stores
or whatever you're doing
to get these books
and then flipping?
How much time
are you allocating?
- [Jonathan] Not as much for
the results I want right now.
- Not as much
time for the results.
- That's his fault.
- Okay, okay,
that's fine, keep talking.
- [Jonathan] I wanted
to, because books though,
like the return for the time
wasn't where I want to be.
Me and my
business partner for the,
I guess because we made
a, like, entity around it.
- Yep.
- [Jonathan] Anyway, we
wanted to scale up the idea.
And so
essentially just create...
So, because for the
book dealing industry,
you have to, like, go to
everyone to get donations.
- Yep.
Like, Goodwill and
thrift stores and everything.
So we just wanted to ask
the main stream of
donations ourselves,
and set up a system around that.
Like, create a
book shop/e-com store.
So, I was
wondering what your thoughts
on the best way
to do that would be.
- Well, if you were
impatient flipping books,
you're about to
get really impatient
because the ambition
you have to build this,
to arb out the
Goodwill and the Salvation Army,
and Amazon resell is a beast.
So, you know, what I would
say is you're gonna need
to really play and
build something big.
It depends on
your ambition, right?
So look, to build a
real platform like that,
you're talking about millions
of dollars in development,
millions of dollars in
advertising, and a decade.
(Jonathan laughing nervously)
- See, that's the problem with
a lot of these kids nowadays,
they want it now
instead of realizing
that you've just gotta
appreciate the process.
- And I'll say
something about Jonathan,
I can tell that him and his
homie wanted to be smarter.
They said,
"Wait a minute," Right?
Like, I can feel it from him.
Jonathan, here's what we say,
if you wanna be the
platform that's such a big game,
everybody wants to be
Uber and Airbnb, and Amazon,
and Google, right?
- [Jonathan] I don't
wanna be the platform,
I still wanna use
Amazon for reselling,
I just wanna get the donation
so I don't have to pay over for
the--
- I know that.
You wanna be a platform.
You wanna be a collection
platform for the inventory
so you can flip it.
The problem is you
have zero awareness.
Nobody knows you exist.
And to build a real awareness,
you have to spend real
money and do a lot of things,
or be very, very bright,
or things of that nature.
I would tell you,
there's a lot of different ways
to think about it.
So, for example, you'll
probably succeed quicker
if you put up signs on trees
all around your neighborhood
and pay kids
$5 an hour to garage sale
and buy every book, and
arbitrage the garbage out.
- Word.
- [Jonathan] Okay.
- You've gotta be annoying.
You've gotta be
DJ Khaled levels of annoying.
- You've gotta be, "Charlamagne
is a fucking asshole,
"but he's my favorite one."
- Absolutely.
You've gotta be
a lovable asshole.
There's nothing wrong
with selling yourself.
- Jonathan, before
you worry about scale,
like, I'm worried
you didn't put enough,
like, one thing
that people don't realize
is there's a lot of
different ways to flip,
meaning you went to books.
That homie Rezy Resells made
a lot of money because
he just went all macro.
He just bought every book
and just made the
arb, and then decided
what to do with the bulk books.
Every single person
watching this right now
can go to
Marshall's, buy sneakers,
flip them on
Amazon and make money.
Every single one.
Now, some people
are happy with $2,000
for 11 hours of work this week.
Others aren't.
You've gotta
figure out if reselling
fits your ambition,
or if you need
to be doing
something altogether different.
What reselling is
really good for, in my opinion,
is for people who wanna
make under 100,000 a year
with the 19 hours a
week that they waste.
That's set.
If you get really good,
and you're lucky,
I was giving that advice
because Envy was
pushing me like, I got nothing,
so I was doing that,
I said dollar store,
I was like, six bucks.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Buy six tchotchkes, make
11 back, go back, buy 11,
11 tchotchkes, 19 back. Go buy
19 tchotchkes, $43 back.
When I hear
two kids got 2,000 to start,
you could make,
that's a $10,000
sneaker flip from Marshall's.
- I wonder what he wants?
Like, what would be a number
that's a good goal to you?
Like, what would you want?
What would make you happy?
- [Jonathan] Well,
what timescale? (laughs)
- Yeah, but,
like, so let's go there.
What's your time worth, bro?
What's your time
worth per hour, Jonathan?
- [Jonathan] Like,
this last week?
- No, no, you've got
this thought in your mind
of my time is
so fucking valuable
that I've gotta
make it efficient.
In your mind, what is
money you wanna make per hour?
- [Jonathan] Well, I don't
have a time worth per hour,
I just have a goal for
like, about 15 years from now.
- What's the goal
15 years from now?
- [Jonathan] Um, couple
of hundred million. (laughs)
- A couple hundred million.
- Good, man.
- [Jonathan] Not like, I have
an actual specific number,
440, but that's good enough,
my ambition is to go to Mars.
- To go to Mars?
- [Jonathan] Yeah.
- Dude, so like, you're telling
me your ultimate ambition
is to go to Mars, not
the 440 million, right?
- [Jonathan] But I want
the money to be able to
make sure I have
three times as much needed.
- So you're
hustling to go to Mars.
The way Gary
hustles to buy the Jets,
he's hustling to got to Mars.
There's nothing wrong with that.
- No, I'm super happy.
Johnathan, I think
you should document.
You should literally document
your journey to Mars, bro.
I'll watch it.
(Cha laughs)
Alright man, good luck,
let's move on.
Listen, I think
that would, listen.
- That's the interrupt,
I've never heard that before.
He's selling books
because he wants to
fly to another world.
(group laughter)
- Let's get one more,
let's get one more.
Listen, I think look,
let's make this
valuable for everybody.
Jonathan is super valuable
to so many of you
the same way Taylor
really hit a nerve
for so many of you.
Jonathan is so worried about
something so macro, so macro.
Do you know how much I worry
about buying the New York Jets?
Goose egg.
Robert Parish.
It's what I'd like to happen,
but I don't think about it
every second,
every little transaction.
Macro transactions,
when I sold a piece
of this fucking
empire to Stephen Ross,
I thought about that because
he's the owner of the Dolphins.
And that whole thing.
But not on every
little transaction,
not when I was selling
books, now when I was doing
every little thing.
Stephanie Land, my ghost writer.
The best in the game.
Did you use a ghost writer?
- No I wrote--
- You wrote,
okay, I'm impressed.
Stephanie's responsible
for all four of those things
actually becoming a real thing.
Who's this?
- [Andy] Shonronda.
- Shonronda?
- [Shonronda] Hello?
- Hello, this is GaryVee
and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show
with Charlamagne Tha God.
- What's up Shonronda?
- [Shonronda] Ahhh get the
fuck outta here, oh my God.
Yo, that's crazy. Yo,
y'all are like the cool, most,
like my most favorite
people ever, like ever.
- That's dope.
- [Shonronda] Like,
it's so crazy.
I never even put my number
in here before, until today.
Like, that's crazy.
- Wait a minute, wait
a minute, wait a minute!
You've never put
your number before?
You didn't love me enough
to put your number before.
It took
Charlamagne to actually do it?
- [Shonronda] No, I never
really watched it live because
I always listen to you at work.
- Respect. I appreciate it.
- [Shonronda] But I'm
always like watching the video.
I don't ever watch it live,
but today it just so happens
that I was able
to watch it live.
- True, true, true.
- Alright, what's your question?
And what's your
name? I didn't catch it.
- [Shonronda] Okay,
it's Shonronda.
- Shonronda. Got it, great.
What's your question?
- [Shonronda] Okay, ah God,
my mind just went blank, okay.
Okay, one question I have
for, Charlamagne, right?
- [Gary] Yep.
- Yes.
- [Shonronda] Okay,
I preordered a book already.
- Thank you!
- [Shonronda] The
Black Privilege book.
- Appreciate that.
- [Gary] Everyone should.
- [Shonronda] And Gary I have
all of your books already,
every one that came out so far.
- [Gary] Stephanie's very happy.
- [Shonronda] So for
Charlamagne, I know that you're
a big believer in The Secret.
- Absolutely.
- [Shonronda] Stuff like that.
So, my thing is, I think
that, how do you feel about
coming out with like, a
documentary video that's
something like The Secret but
more for the quote unquote
urban type areas?
'Cause I feel like
that's something that
the black community in
particular is missing out on,
as far as keeping your your
energy high, being positive,
stuff like that.
And I think that would change
a lot of what's going on
in society.
- Yeah, you're absolutely right.
That's why I named by
book Black Privilege, because
I said that we have to
start finding privilege
in ourselves, we have
to start realizing that
we're special too,
and that's how I grew up,
I grew up with them
teaching me about black power,
and black pride, and black
excellence, and black kings,
and the black man is God.
- And who did that?
- Just studying,
studying like the Five Percent.
- But what about
your inner circle?
- Yeah, my father, my
father always kept me watching
Elijah Muhammad videos, and
Minister Farrakhan videos,
they just kept pushing
black excellence in my head.
So that's actually why I
named my book Black Privilege,
for that exact reason,
because I feel like we have to
change our mindset,
because everything starts
with a mindset.
Like if you wake up in
the morning and you feel like
you can't do something,
it won't get done.
And I feel like all
this talk of white supremacy
and white privilege,
which is very real, has created
a black inferiority
complex in our people,
so that's exactly why I named
my book Black Privilege,
and then the subtitle
is very important too,
opportunity comes
to those who create it.
So I feel like we can start
creating our own opportunities
simply by changing our mindset.
That's exactly why I named
my book Black Privilege.
- There's two ways to build
the biggest building in town.
One is to build the
biggest building in town,
and that's what
you're talking about.
The other is to tear down
everybody else's building.
And I think when you
talk about black privilege
or white privilege,
when you peel away at that,
94% of the people are trying to
tear people's buildings down.
People hear black privilege,
and I've been watching
how people have been
acting, they think that comes
at the cost of
somebody who's white, or Asian.
- Not true.
- That's crazy!
When people
hear white privilege,
look, I understand
the macro belief that
it comes at the cost of,
except the people that have
the mindset of black privilege!
This is not a black-white,
girl-boy issue.
This is a
positive-negative issue.
- That's it. That's it.
And we all
have divine privilege,
because we're all here!
Listen, I know I keep
going back to this but I.
- [Gary] 400 trillion to one.
- That's it,
400 trillion to one,
I love when Gary says
that because it's so real,
you almost gotta
see it for yourself.
Next time you have sex
and the guy busts off on you,
just look at all those sperm
cells and realize only one
can be a child!
- But wait a minute,
wait a minute,
knowing a little
bit about sperm,
enough to talk about this,
how are you
actually able to see it?
You don't take it and
put it into a microscope.
You can't really see it.
- You never busted
off on a girl, Gary?
What you mean?
- No no, of course,
but you can't see.
- Oh, because they swim.
- You can't see the
four hundred trillion sperms.
- Oh, gotcha, gotcha, gotcha.
- You can't either!
- You right.
- What are you like, take it
and putting it on a microscope?
What, have you got a
microscope by your bed?
- I just assume when I look
at it, when it's on my wife,
I'm like that's 400 trillion.
(group laughter)
I just assume.
- [Gary] So did we
answer the question?
- [Shonronda] Yes,
yes, Charlamagne did.
Can I ask you a question, Gary?
- Of course, go fast.
- [Shonronda] Okay,
I've been trying to start
a beekeeper company.
- A beekeeper?
- [Shonronda] Yeah, a beekeeper.
- Wooooow.
This is dope, this is new ideas.
- Where's my honey? Go ahead.
- [Shonronda] What do
you think would be a good way
to kind of promote that?
I'm trying to do urban
beekeeping and stuff like that,
I'm trying to push that to the
urban and black communities.
- I don't like that word, urban.
Why does
everything have to be urban?
- [Shonronda] I know you don't.
I just hate to be so,
'cause it's not
just black people
in particular that
I'm talking about.
It's black people,
Mexicans, Spanish people.
- Yeah and there's not black
bees, Mexican bees, white bees.
Bees are bees.
If people got a bee problem,
they gonna want
you to help them.
- [Gary] Well, you
didn't call it Human Privilege.
- That's true. (laughs)
- [Shonronda]
People in urban areas.
- Listen, listen, listen.
Real quick.
If you wanna be
the black beekeeper,
I think that's brilliant.
Are you good at it?
- [Shonronda] I'm
trying to be. (laughs)
- Well let's start there.
It doesn't matter if you're
black, white, rich, or poor:
if you stink at your
skill, you're gonna lose.
- [Shonronda] Okay.
- So, before you try to build
this brand, why don't you
go work for a beekeeper
for a year, and get taught
the proper way to be one?
- [Shonronda] Okay.
- Yeah, because you ain't
gonna convince no black people
that they need a beekeeper.
That's just an
expense I don't need.
I'm gonna be honest with you.
- [Shonronda] I kinda know that.
I kinda figured that.
- [Gary] No, no, but
listen, can I ask you
a really interesting question?
'Cause now I'm excited.
Is there a a reason
you want to do that?
You like bees?
Tell the truth.
You think there's money in it?
Somebody once
told you something?
- [Shonronda] Truthfully, I
know that there's money in it.
Because there's a lot more to
the beehive than just honey.
- I agree.
- [Shonronda] You
got propolis, you got,
there's a lot of stuff,
there's beeswax, royal jelly.
There's a lot to it.
And then the services
that come along with it,
like bee removal, pollination.
- Listen, my young man.
Listen, I like
that answer a whole lot.
I'm gonna give you a very.
How old are you? 22.
- [Shonronda] No, 30.
- Nice.
You're a very, very young man.
Go work for a beekeeper.
- I think that's a woman, Gary.
- [Gary] Oh, sorry, are you?
- [Shonronda] Yeah.
- I apologize, thank you.
- [Shonronda] Yeah
I get that all the time.
- Trust me, good news,
I get the reverse
of it all the time too.
I call down to the
hotel and they're like,
your towels will
be right up, ma'am.
(Cha laughs)
Listen to me, you are
an extremely young woman.
Go work for somebody for
two years, learn the craft,
and do your thing.
You can be on a 10 year
mission, you'll be 40 years old,
a year younger than
me, how old are you?
- I'll be 37 this year, I think.
- A few years older than
Cha, and you can absolutely
win this game, but you're
not gonna convince anybody
about anything unless
you are actually the part.
We are living through the
greatest fronting PR moves
of all time because
people think taking the pictures
on Instagram proves it.
It does not, and if you have
a passion for this, and you
gave a great answer,
you actually understand
there's something there.
I need you to
actually then get good at it,
and then you can
actually succeed.
- [Shonronda] Okay,
sounds great.
Thank y'all so much, man.
- Great, thank you
so much, thank you.
- I only know one
person who had a bee problem,
and that was Dr. Oz,
because when you go to
the Dr. Oz show, he
gives you jars of honey.
And the reason he started
giving out jars of honey is
because he had a bee problem,
so he hired some beekeepers to
come in, and they came in
and started keeping the bees,
and now he
harvests his own honey.
- Do you know honey's actually
one of the only things in
the world that I don't like?
- I love honey, I put honey
in my green tea every morning.
- And I'm trying to
make myself like it.
Because I did
that with cilantro.
I didn't like it, and
then I just kept eating it
until I loved it.
- I don't even know what
cilantro is, when you said that
I though that was the
dude that sang Whip Nae Nae.
(Gary laughs)
(phone ringing)
- [Andy] Miguel.
- Coriander?
- [Miguel] This is Miguel.
- Miguel, this is GaryVee
and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show
with Charlamagne Tha God.
- [Miguel] Man, ridiculous,
Charlamagne what's going on?
GaryVee, thanks so
much for giving me a call.
- What's up, brother?
- Of course my man,
what's your question?
- [Miguel] Alright, so
I'm a beginning Loan Officer
in the state of Arizona.
Alright, so I'm an analytics
guy, I'm one of those cats that
you look at my Instagram
I have 500 people following me
and I get 120,
130 likes per post.
That makes me happy, right?
- Okay?
- [Miguel] So, I'm
trying to jump that up.
I'm trying to be patient,
I have to learn patience
from you Gary like
nobody's fucking business.
- I don't think Gary has
patience to be honest with you.
- [Gary] I surely do.
- [Miguel] Patience
is my worst enemy by far.
I would stab myself
in the foot if I could,
not to waste something.
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- [Miguel] So that's my question
- That's the problem.
You think you're wasting,
you haven't calibrated time.
Charlamagne's
making a joke but like,
I'm so macro patient it's crazy.
I think in 30, 40, 50,
60 year terms all the time.
It's the only way I think.
And so you think
you're wasting time
and I'm thinking that
I'm picking up context.
When I'm doing things
that don't get instant results,
that 99% of people
think is wasting time,
I'm happy because I'm
getting data from the reaction.
If you're such an analytics
guy, you're an analytics guy
on the math front, you're
not an analytics guy in life.
If you're an analytics guy
- [Miguel] Right.
- In life you
understand that all the things
that are doing things that
don't create instant results
are frameworks and
bricks to the reality
of what you're building.
- Yeah I gotta
chapter in my book, and then
the whole chapter's
basically based off of there's
no such thing as losses in life.
You either win or you learn.
So it's like if you're
not getting the results
you want in that
moment you should
be learning
something from that experience.
- Let's take a step back.
It's imperative
that you figure out
who you're
trying to prove this to.
Patience comes--
- Myself.
- Yeah so I think
- [Miguel] Myself, 100%.
- Great, then you need to start
loving yourself
a whole lot more.
- Absolutely.
- You're judging
the shit out of yourself
in a very poor way.
- [Miguel] Hell yeah,
I'm so critical to myself.
I'm fucking critical to myself
and if I have to learn that,
a whole lot more
too because now this
is my first 100%
commission job, gig, ever.
- Right.
So for me coming from
that corporate mindset to,
fuck if I don't
go out there and
work and actually
did my job now,
I'm gonna shoot
myself in the foot.
So that in itself is a
fucking piece of me saying
- The other--
- Why do hate your feet, bro?
You wanna stab
yourself in the foot,
shoot yourself in the foot?
What's wrong wit your foot?
- [Miguel] Charlamagne
what happens when
you can't walk right, bro?
It fucks up your day,
it fucks up your life.
It fucks up your mentality,
you can't run, you can't jump.
- Yeah.
- [Miguel] That's why
I always joke about my feet.
- That's so weird.
This is a funny thing about
mindsets, when you said that
I was like, I would
dominate on a wheelchair.
(Cha laughs)
- [Gary] It was weird, I swear,
it's super funny like I--
- That's why Gary can't lose.
- You know what?
I think that's right man.
- Isn't that right man.
It was really interesting
to me, I heard you say that
and was like man if
I was in a wheelchair,
I would milk the shit out of it.
I would create stuff.
(Cha chuckles)
- I would like, I would
come up with a sneaker brand
which would then be funny.
You know like, I would do stuff.
- That's funny cause
Professor X was in a wheelchair
but he was the
leader of the X-Men, no!
But he was the thinker.
- [Gary] I get it.
- He was the thinker.
- [Gary] My man I think there--
- That makes perfect sense
Because, that
makes perfect sense
that you say that too because
it's a smart, smart market
you can make
yourself go into it,
I understand what you're saying.
- Listen my man
- [Miguel] I need a
Fitbit and I turn it up
a little bit more on here.
- I'm telling you,
you're beating yourself up.
You're beating yourself
up, which means immediately
you're set up to lose.
So for example I'm listening
to you and I like your vibe,
and I'm like dammit,
he's probably not gonna
be successful at this thing.
'Cause that's
what I defaulted to,
I'm always ready for the loss.
And I'm saying when
he's not gonna be successful
at this 100% commission
job, he's gonna go through
a shitty phase cause
he came from corporate
where he was protected, he
went out into the real world.
I have no idea what
he's selling, right?
He may be selling that's not
that good of an item to sell,
he might not be good
at selling that item.
And he's gonna decide in nine
months that he's not good,
and that's gonna
take him three, four years
to get out of that cloud.
And so I'm sitting
here nervous Miguel,
I'm kinda happy you called.
Because if I could do anything,
please do this for me.
When you fail at this 100%
commission thing, be happy.
And that is gonna be so
ridiculously hard for you,
I can taste it already,
but remember I said that.
Today, tomorrow
and 10 weeks from now.
What do you say
about that?
- I think I kinda fore,
I kinda forecasted
that on my own too cause
I like to, again, analytics.
And seeing myself and
analyzing myself often.
And I had a position open up
to me this last week for a team.
Which, I mean a lot of
the marketing shit would
get off my own back.
But, at the same
time I was learning.
And I heard you say
that a couple weeks ago,
sometimes you have to take
a step back so you can learn
your trades become a tradesman.
I learnt in a now,
I haven't been in mortgage
since September last year, bro.
I can sell (inaudible)
if I really want to.
But at the end of the day,
not everybody needs a mortgage
every single fucking
minute of their lives.
- That's real
- [Gary] Yep.
That's exactly right
- So.
- You either win
or you learn man.
- And another thing too that,
- [Miguel] The industry
that I'm in is so fucking
detail-making goal, from A to Z,
so many different options,
that it's really
impossible for me right now,
nine, three, four
months in the way,
that I'll learn everything
because I won't see that much
business come through my
pipeline to be
able to learn from.
So, I jump back I'm like--
- So, so.
Take a step back
- It makes me feel like a fool
- Let's, we're
being very logical here.
So, if that's all
true, which it is,
why are you judging
yourself on the first quarter
in a triple overtime game?
You gotta do this
for a decade before
you can decide if you did it.
- [Miguel] Right, I
guess I'm just being
too fucking
critical of myself, I'm just,
I'm not sure I fucking went.
- You know so,
you know what's so
crazy about patience?
- [Gary] No, no, real
quick I apologize,
please don't forget,
'cause I'm gonna get
yelled at for interrupting you.
You wanna win quick.
If you just wanted
to win, you'd be calm.
- Yeah.
- I'm super calm
'cause I just wanna win.
- You know you will.
- I just.
I just know it's a 50 year game.
The hell am I getting
excited or bent outta shape of?
When I met Steph Land,
'cause she's here
and I like using
anything that's in the room.
Right?
People, products.
We were talking about
social media, Crush It!
In 2008, cause
it came out in '09.
I will never
forget that meeting Steph.
I was talking about
stuff that nobody knew what it,
what like, you
understood it cause you'd work
with Seth Godin and stuff,
you were right for me.
'Cause you
understood it conceptually,
but the details
in it was like silly.
- Well it was just,
can this really be done?
- [Gary] Right.
- Or you're the anomaly.
- That was the question.
- You know what, thank you.
I remember sitting
there writing Crush It!
And feeling the cynicism from
the team, not in a bad way,
'cause everybody was very nice,
as you can see she's lovely.
But it was like,
no but wait a minute.
No you can't you on YouTube
and Twitter and just live
your dream like.
Like is this?
- [Stephanie] Well you could
obviously you could do it.
- Right.
If you were somebody
- And somebody else do it.
- Right.
And what I knew was the
long tail would be there.
I knew there would be
the hundreds of thousands
of people on Instagram
right now making 71,000,
89,000, not everybody's
gonna make a trillion.
So, dude you gotta be patient.
You're not doing it
'cause you just wanna win,
you're doing it
'cause you wanna win fast.
- Yeah, and I
thought I basically
was gonna have
the same sentiment.
The thing about life is
you can't fast-forward life.
It's gonna take,
it's gonna be five years,
it's gonna be 10 years,
the hours, 60 minutes.
We can't speed up the process
regardless of how
much we think we can.
So you just gotta
live the process out.
- [Miguel] Word, well
I appreciate you guys.
Man, keep on killin it.
- Alright, my man.
Take care yourself.
- [Miguel] I love
you're confident.
- Thank you.
- GaryVee.
- [Gary] A real pleasure, man.
- Thank you, man.
Listen, I need to
sell 100,000 books
in my first week like GaryVee.
- [Gary] 104.
- Okay, 104.
What's the exact number, 104?
- No actually 100, was it 100?
And 500, 100?
- 100 and?
- [Gary] Top left number 549?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Top left number.
- That's an amazing
feat by the way.
- [Iris] 100,549.
- And that's for
The #AskGaryVee book.
- Let's help this
man sell 100,550 books
so he can always make fun of me.
- Black Privilege: Opportunity
Comes to Those Who Create It,
it's eight principles
that I've learned in my life
that I'm sharing
with the people.
Okay, I'm not an
expert at anything,
I just got a little experience
in life because I've lived.
And that's all you can ask for
once you live a little bit.
- [Gary] You lived a little.
- I've lived a little,
that's it, that's
it I've lived a little.
- [Gary] Question of
the day, ask him.
You get to ask a
question of the day,
any question you want.
They'll answer and
get thousands of answers.
This might be a time
to do market research,
this might be an
opportunity to see
something you're curious
about, this is your shot.
- My question is simple,
do you believe that there is
such a thing as black privilege?
Like do you
believe that you can find
privilege in your blackness?
- And can we use Blackness
as an all-encompassing?
- Yeah.
Can we see it as a
perceived shortcoming?
'Cause that's what it is.
- Yeah it's perceived
as a shortcoming.
I mean I want people
even when they see this,
I don't want
them to think that the
book is just for black
people because it's not.
It's for anybody who's
ever feel marginalized,
anybody has ever felt depressed,
anybody who feels
like they lack privilege.
Like I feel like it's a divine.
- [Gary] I've
got Jets privilege.
- You got Jets privilege.
- [Gary] I mean it.
All these Giants
fans run around,
they think
they're so cool and happy.
What they don't realize
is the Yankees and Rangers
won championships for me
and I dropped
them like a bad habit.
And now I'm all
about the Knicks and Jets
because I love to climb.
(Cha laughs)
So you Giant fans,
you have it bad.
Patriot fans
think they're so good.
I laugh at all these
kids running around when
they had their
self-esteem wrapped up
in their football team.
- You know what's
so funny about that?
- [Gary] Who
gives a shit if your
football team is good?
Are you good, mother fucker?
- I'm a Dallas Cowboys fan.
So I always tell Patriots fans,
there's going to
come a point where ya'll
down for like five, six years.
It's going to happen.
Trust me.
We dominated the 90's.
- [Gary] When that
mother fucker retires
at 50 years old.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Fucking piece of shit.
- Absolutely.
Thank you for having me, Gary.
- [Gary] You keep
asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
- My man.
(hip hop music)